Takashi 69 is set to receive zero jail
time and and and he's gonna go into
witness protection what where where is
Takashi 69 going into witness protection
what is he gonna be a headmaster at the
Crayola summer camp where is this dude
what's he gonna be a [ __ ] what's he
gonna do a stableboy in Narnia
where is take Hoshi six not what's he
gonna be all right just somebody in West
Hollywood how are you gonna hide this
little rainbow gonna Potamus in witness
protection then what are they gonna do
they're gonna hire a bunch of other
people to dress up like Takashi every
day Woody's he he's gonna be a um elf
and uh what's he gonna be he gonna be an
elf at Michael Jackson's sons house
Michael Jackson got that big you know
that uh you know that rubenesque his son
always wearing him winter coats and [ __ ]
it'd be two hundred agrees outside okay
that dude have on ninety pounds of
ostrich he gonna have little Takashi's
hitting it in here just or just working
as a gardener on that ostrich you know
it's just gonna get wild huh what's he
gonna need gonna work at a [ __ ] aunt
Annies or something in the mall how are
you gonna hide people from that man you
don't think it's somebody gonna you have
the number 69 tattooed on his face where
you gonna do that huh what is he gonna
be what is he gonna do for work be armed
calculator
what's he gonna be a math test how are
you gonna hide him
were you gonna hide him he's gonna do
Tarot car you're gonna do numerology
what's he gonna do the man have a 69
written on the side of his face and he
has rainbow hair witness protection
actually I bet in Reno nobody know bro
they must I bet they'd have to put him
in a senior care center that's what I
would think or a zoo but you know even
even in the zoo a couple of horses are
gonna be like [ __ ] hard and that
didn't witness protection
which again what's he gonna do is gonna
be Louie Anderson's pool boy how you
gonna hide that man dude he gonna be
performing sexual favors for Hollywood
executive producers in no time that's
the only that's the only place I think
you could hide him where you know people
would notice but they probably really
wouldn't care is having him do sexual
favors for the Hollywood elite good luck
dude good luck Wow you know it's crazy
as my sister can't even read but what
does it have to do with us right now
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one